trying to get your kid into a Harvard or
Yale there's an algorithm for that and
it measures their true odds
parents are obsessed with getting their
kids into the best colleges like NYU and
these same schools are obsessed with
keeping their top rankings in part by
attracting lots of applicants after all
a growing denominator with a fixed
numerator creates shrinking percentages
reflecting slim acceptance rates and
enticing exclusivity it's no wonder the
college application process feels rigged
think of the costs involved both in
money and time prepping for multiple AP
exams year-round travel Sports
extracurriculars campus visits private
College counseling application fees and
for what schools like to talk up their
holistic admissions process where they
carefully weigh each student's unique
attributes alongside conventional
academic credentials when the truth is
it's a black box
so a couple of c-suite Executives took
action they formed a non-profit called
transparency in admissions using the
piles of data Harvard was forced to
disclose in a lawsuit over its race
conscious admissions policies the team
extrapolated those results to other top
schools to determine the probabilities
of admission for different populations
as frustrated parents themselves the
executives say their goal is to save
other families anxiety and money by
providing a snapshot of students true
odds here's how students take an online
survey input details like ethnicity
household income grades they pay up to
25 and in return receive a list of
acceptance probabilities at the top
schools based on their individual
profile
bottom line you have a bit of an edge if
say you're recruited athlete or a child
of big donors or first generation
college student by and large the data
show that huge Slots of students have
almost zero chance of getting into the
most elite schools now this is something
you might have suspected before you
began this journey but now you have the
data to back it up